allez notre émission spéciale continue
je vais recevoir dans un instant des
experts politologues spécialistes de la
communication politique on va commencer
justement par évaluer l'exercice de
l'interview télé ce choix d'égiter de
13h pour s'exprimer Emmanuel Macron
a-t-il touché sa cible première réponse
Fabien avec elle
sa parole était attendue le président de
la République est resté inflexible la
réforme des retraites est nécessaire et
doit être appliqué d'ici la fin de
l'année entre les sondages et le court
terme et l'intérêt général du pays je
choisis l'intérêt général du pays et
s'il faut derrière endosser
l'impopularité aujourd'hui je
l'endoserai Emmanuel Macron a certes
regretté avoir manqué de pédagogie pour
convaincre les Français mais à réaffirmé
la légitimité du recours aux 49-3 et le
caractère démocratique de la réforme le
but c'était là encore de montrer de
faire la démonstration qui ne se
considérait pas comme affaibli par cette
séquence politique et que comme il
n'était pas affaibli bien il n'avait pas
à bouger et il devait pour des raisons
évidentes de nécessité en tout cas ce
sont les arguments qu'il a développé il
fallait absolument que ce projet réforme
passe en l'état pas de quoi apaiser la
colère de la rue pour cette expert en
communication de crise ce n'était
d'ailleurs pas vraiment l'objectif du
président la difficulté pourrait
Emmanuel Macron dans cette intervention
c'était d'abord de parler à ces
électeurs à son camp et c'est ce qu'il a
fait en choisissant se format du JT 13h
qu'il a grand Metz des retraités qui
sont eux majoritairement favorables à ce
que les actifs qu'ils ne sont plus
travaillent plus longtemps une prise de
parole qui ne devrait donc pas faire
bouger les lignes à la veille d'une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation le chef
de l'État devrait à nouveau s'adresser
aux Français dans les prochaines
semaines
[Musique]
tout de suite les invités de ce second
débat Maria martial Foucault bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directeur du cevipov
Emily zappalski bonsoir bienvenue
spécialiste en communication politique
fondatrice directrice de l'agence Émilie
conseil vous êtes passé en 24 heures du
côté édit son côté invité expert mais
vous remplissez très bien les deux rôles
Florent va dire bonsoir bienvenue à vous
président de l'été ri c'est un sac de
réflexion qui a pour jouer et de
produire et de diffuser une réflexion de
gauche sur l'ensemble des sujets qui
structurent la vie politique française
vous êtes également enseignant à
Sciences Po Mathieu croissando est
évidemment resté à mes côtés allez
peut-être à un point de vue un peu
général on va commencer comme ça Marcel
Foucault qu'est ce qui ressort pour vous
de cette interview d'Emmanuel Macron
la confirmation qu'Emmanuel Macron ne
pouvait pas convaincre
au fond quel que soit les les éléments
de langage la forme le fond il était
dans un exercice impossible impossible
parce que à partir du moment où il avait
presque dévoilé avant avant le 13h du
jour qu'il n'y avait aucun instrument
alternatif institutionnel une
dissolution un référendum retirer le
texte bon il était dans un exercice qui
ne pouvait pas convaincre les
oppositions ne pouvait pas convaincre
l'ensemble des personnes qui sont
mobilisées depuis près de deux mois et
d'ailleurs je m'interroge est-ce qu'il a
totalement convaincu
c'est ses propres
alliés les parlementaires de sa majorité
parce que au fond ce qu'il a indiqué sur
maintenant qu'est-ce qui va se passer il
y a peu de choses qui sont ressorties de
ce de son intervention ce fait dire je
suis un président très légitimiste je
finalement je me mets dans les pas de
des institutions je j'ai toujours été
présenté comme un président réformateur
donc je suis ma feuille de route et
alors je pense pas qu'on puisse parler
nécessairement de mépris vis-à-vis des
opposants mais c'est presque une forme
d'entêtement et qui est qui correspond à
ce qu'il a toujours indiqué est fait par
le passé il y a eu un moment où il a pu
surprendre c'est au moment de la crise
covid ou il est devenu ce président très
interventionniste et prêt à ouvrir le
robinet des des deniers publics mais
d'ailleurs il justifie la réforme des
retraites par cette par cette période là
exactement dépensé que on peut pas faire
autrement ce qui est peut-être plus
surprenant je dirais c'est cette
peut-être cette méconnaissance ou si
j'étais extrêmement dur je dirais
presque une forme d'inculture politique
de ce qu'est la démocratie parlementaire
et moi j'ai été frappé quand même qu'il
n'est pas pris
enfin totalement le pouls de ce qui
s'est passé au Parlement
il l'a jamais été parlementaire
donc je crois que ça révèle aussi un
président qui a un rapport à la pratique
du pouvoir et à une culture politique
très étonnante par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs puisque il les a à tour de
rôle mis sur le grill en disant que ils
n'ont pas fait les réformes que lui seul
s'apprête à faire
vous répondir à la question pourquoi le
le finalement choisir le journal de 13h
et qui est une cible particulière et
s'il a touché cette cible pour vous je
sais pas si il a touché cette cible en
tout cas c'était l'idée de choisir aussi
un moment qui était pas trop solennel
parce que en effet on attendait pas
d'annonce et il y a pas eu d'annonce
spécifiquement il y a eu juste une
justification pour moi c'était beaucoup
de justification ce qui s'est passé
pendant ce discours justification
explication sur les objectifs il a
beaucoup insisté sur l'idée de dire ça
ne fait pas plaisir je ne le fais pas
avec plaisir et il a expliqué peut-être
c'est la première fois qu'il explique et
qu'il assume totalement les objectifs de
la réforme sur l'aspect équilibre
financier et qui n'insiste beaucoup
là-dessus maintenant est-ce qu'il a
touché sa cible moi je pense que c'était
pas forcément attendu le contenu c'était
important qui s'adresse aux Français
parce que c'était un moment ça fait
longtemps qu'il y a eu son absence ou en
tout cas qui nous parlait de loin et je
pense que c'était important qu'il en
parle mais il a pas du tout été en
empathie il a été très formel il a
commencé par dire que que la réforme
elle avait été votée alors votée si on
parle d'une motion de sang survoter en
tout cas elle était adoptée et après il
est resté que sur des choses tangibles
assez concrète mais tout à fait tangible
moi ce qui m'a surpris juste pour un
élément qui m'a beaucoup surpris et
peut-être on y reviendra c'est quand il
a parlé du Capitole là je trouvais que
alors on comprend l'idée de cibler
Jean-Luc Mélenchon le méchant qui a fait
monter toute la sauce pour qui est cette
révolte on comprend
non mais on entend quand même j'ai pas
entendu en tout cas moi j'ai
l'impression quand même entre
oui et puis ce qu'on a entendu la veille
ce qu'on a entendu même dans la bouche
d'Elisabeth borne ça préparé le terrain
on comprend l'intention de vouloir
condamner évidemment ces violences et de
pouvoir braquer l'opinion publique
principalement son électorat mais
peut-être de rassembler d'autres
françaises qui seraient embêtés que ça
prenne cette ampleur parce que ça fait 6
soir que que ça pète quand même à Paris
ici ou là pas d'une manière générale on
comprend d'autres villes et dans
d'autres villes Rennes Nantes mais alors
allez jusqu'à Capitole là j'ai moi pour
moi c'était on aura le temps de d'y
revenir et de vous entendre les uns les
autres Matthieu ou lui intervenir moi ce
qui m'a frappé c'est comment il qualifie
la situation actuelle il y a une forme
de contradiction incroyable parce que à
l'écouter on n'est pas dans une crise
sociale et politique majeure à l'écouter
on a des gens en colère dont la colère
est légitime parce que les efforts
demandés sont difficiles ça c'est à peu
près nouveau mais c'est ce qu'on a
entendu et de l'autre côté on a
effectivement c'est le Capitole ou le
Brésil de bolsonaro donc faut choisir et
il le résume d'une formule qui est assez
étonnante il dit
c'est un moment que j'assume qui en
permettra d'autres donc c'est un mauvais
moment à passer d'une certaine façon
comme si il y avait pas une ligne de
fracture comme si il y avait pas voilà
c'est c'est un moment c'est une secousse
c'est un soubresaut c'est une péripétie
alors mais j'ai pas le sentiment qui qui
qui est le même diagnostic que d'autres
peuvent avoir sur la situation que
connaît notre pays on va rester un peu
sur la forme avec vous Florent Vaillot
alors moi j'ai entendu l'interview en
fait à la radio dans ma voiture d'abord
oui c'est dommage parce que le vous
dites que le langage corporel était
important pourquoi et la première chose
qui m'a énormément frappé c'est qu'il
Emmanuel Macron avait un sourire qui
était très ironique très très méprisant
méprisant vous dites vous employés le
terme je trouve qu'il accompagnait
ponctuait ces phrases ces assertion d'un
sourire parfois il mettait en scène le
fait de ne pas finir ses phrases il y
avait des bras qui s'ouvraient qui se
refermaient c'est vraiment la
à l'égard de la politique du président
de la République et en particulier à
l'égard de la manière dont ils gèrent le
pays et ce qu'il propose aux françaises
de français en particulier la réforme
des retraites et le président que dit-il
vous n'avez rien compris à ce que je
fais je n'ai pas bien réussi à vous
expliquer et puis finalement vous êtes
bêtes vous êtes le confinement vous a
abruti je suis plus intelligent que tout
le monde et j'ai raison envers et contre
tout martial Foucault vous disiez tout à
l'heure j'emploie pas le terme méprisant
pourquoi oui parce que je je trouve que
le l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron
ressemble à beaucoup d'interventions
quand il y a eu des moments je verrai de
petites crises souvenons-nous sur au
moment du mouvement gilet jaune cette
intervention au mois de décembre il y
avait certes une forme de solennité de
fermeté mais il y a toujours
effectivement je crois que vous avez
employé le terme Thomas de
d'arrogance en tout cas un certain
nombre d'opposants
c'est un président arrogant dans des
situations
de tension ou finalement sa ligne
s'aligne politique et est mise en
difficulté ou est fragilisée alors
pourquoi je disais que le terme méprime
m'ennuie dans pour résumer cette
intervention il y aurait eu mépris dans
l'intervention si Emmanuel Macron avait
indiqué que finalement les Français ne
souhaitent pas travailler davantage que
l'ensemble des opposants était
illégitimes que les mobilisations ne
sont pas justifiées alors il a employé
je crois à trois reprises le terme
respect j'ai dû respect alors finalement
c'est presque c'est le minimum qu'on
pouvait attendre s'il ne voulait pas
être accusé sur le terrain du mépris moi
ce qui me semble ressortir c'est la
distinction qu'on doit faire entre un
président est-ce que c'est un président
qui entend est-ce que c'est un président
qui écoute et qui tire des conséquences
politiques
bonifacement il y a il y a il y a une
forme de je dirais presque de temps
censure de sa part à ne pas vouloir il
la suggère
ensuite Émilie sur on termine sur le
mépris après on passe à autre chose
pardon le président de la République a
été parfois je trouve beaucoup plus
méprisant par exemple lorsqu'il dit on
nous a pas disputé le sens des
responsabilités et la journaliste le
reprend mais ils n'ont rien proposé et
dit-il ne finissant pas cette phrase
lorsqu'il explique que on est dans un
pays qui parfois ne veut pas comprendre
les réformes difficiles parce qu'il y en
a qui effectivement comprennent et puis
d'autres qui ne veulent pas comprendre
le passage sur le covid de déni de
réalité qu'il reproche à certains
Français mais il ne dit même pas comme
auparavant on se souvient quand Gilles
Legendre disant manque de pédagogie
c'est même plus que ils n'ont ils ont
manqué de pédagogie c'est que les gens
n'ont pas compris donc soit les gens
n'ont pas compris soit ils n'ont pas
voulu comprendre c'était vraiment ça
l'argument il y avait même pas ce mea
culpa sur le manque de pédagogie alors
que oui mais l'explication nous
interrompre le déni des réalités c'est
une critique qu'on peut faire par
exemple à l'opposition de gauche qui
veut revenir à la retraite à 60 ans oui
mais la différence
la différence c'est que quand on est
dans l'opposition on le sait en France
tous les excès sont permis on le paye
lorsqu'on arrive au pouvoir
indéniablement mais quand on est au
pouvoir il faut tout de même faire
attention parce qu'on a une majorité et
sa majorité elle n'est pas aussi soudée
que ça derrière le bon votre ami
là-dessus moi j'ai pas trouvé dans la
forme méprisante vraiment comme on a pu
le voir plein de fois beaucoup plus
méprisant c'est globalement le message
qui est envoyé ce que vous disiez
Mathieu c'est il répond pas à la
question qui est posée dans la rue parce
que la question elle a changé depuis
jeudi dernier c'est moi la réforme des
retraites c'est la façon dont ça a été
voté c'est l'utilisation du 49-3 c'est
cette démocratie qui ne fonctionne plus
c'est cette majorité de population qui
est contre mais qui ne se fait pas
entendre et là-dessus il n'a pas voulu
répondre et encore une fois les premiers
mots c'est de dire cette réforme elle
est légitime parce qu'elle a été votée
parce que motion de censure et juste un
autre mot il y a un grand mépris mais
pas dans pas dans la forme mais
simplement dans dans ce qu'il dit sur
les syndicats il dit des syndicats et il
a dit à plusieurs reprises que moi je
trouvais que c'était incroyable on va
négocier d'autres choses avec les
syndicat non mais on va négocier aussi
autre chose avec les syndicats alors il
dit oui pas tout de suite en gros on les
laisse cours de récréation demain
puisque c'est la manifestation mais on
reprendra bien vite sur le travail sur
les conditions de travail sur l'usure
professionnelle c'est ce que demandait
geoffroyce des yeux se maintient dans
les eaux en disant faites confiance aux
partenaires sociaux mais parce que les
partenaires sociaux ils arrivent à faire
des compromis et je trouvais que c'était
très méprisant de dire vous arrivez pas
à faire des compromis mais on va revenir
vous chercher alors que je pense que les
relations sont suffisamment abîmées
aujourd'hui pour qu'il y ait besoin un
petit peu de réconcilier ça avant de
pouvoir se projeter dans d'autres
chantiers là c'est méprisant alors on
reste sur la communication avec Marion
Bigot on va comparer un peu ce qui s'est
dit et la méthode de communication du
Président de la République aujourd'hui
avec finalement ça non communication
dans les semaines qui ont précédé depuis
le début de l'examen du texte de la
réforme des retraites non communication
avec l'impression que depuis le recours
aux 49-3 jeudi dernier le président de
la République reprend la main s'active
multiplie les consultations dans la
majorité après quasiment un mois et demi
de silence si on se retourne sur cette
séquence on constate que le président a
envoyé de temps en temps des petites
cartes postales sur la réforme comme à
Rungis notamment avec la France qui se
lève tôt ou dans sa lettre en réponse à
l'intersydical mais globalement on peut
parler d'un président absent un
président qui a laissé ses équipes aller
au front quitte à s'abîmer ainsi lorsque
le texte est en discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale avait qu'on se rappelle des
échanges très tendus Emmanuel Macron est
à la conférence de Munich en Allemagne
et lorsque l'examen du texte débute au
Sénat il est en tourné en Afrique
centrale et refuse de s'exprimer sur le
sujet pour le spécialiste en
communication philippe Moreau Chevrolet
l'éloignement géographique du président
à ce moment-là de la discussion est une
erreur
erreur qu'il a déjà commise par le passé
écoutez-le c'est quelque chose qu'on
observe en général dans les périodes de
crise aiguë pendant la période des
gilets jaunes au moment les plus forts
de la crise il était à Buenos air il
était en Argentine pour je crois à
sommet du G8 là il est parti pour une
tournée africaine
il a tendance à disparaître de la scène
disons quand les choses deviennent
vraiment
difficiles politiquesment et à revenir
un peu plus tard pour au fond quand la
chose est un petit peu plus négociable
le gouvernement en première ligne donc
est des équipes gouvernementales qui
ressortent épuisée de cette séquence le
président réapparaît et reprend la main
tel un sauveur tout en étant encore
obligé de réexpliquer à nouveau sa
réforme signe qu'il sait quelque part
engagé trop vite dans ce texte qu'il ne
l'a pas suffisamment incarné avant les
débats écoutez à nouveau à ce sujet
Philippe moreauchevrelet c'est peut-être
davantage cadrer les choses au départ
c'est-à-dire avant de laisser le
gouvernement s'en occuper lui donner
plus de d'atouts dans la bataille ça lui
donner vraiment un sens pour cette
réforme lui donner vraiment des éléments
près des choses qui peuvent vraiment
être défendues pas des choses un peu
bancales comme les 1200 euros mais
vraiment des choses des fondables
durables sur lesquels il pouvait pas
être attaqué par la suite
en tout cas le silence présidentiel
renforce également aujourd'hui son
isolement et mettent en avance et
mettent en évidence pardon quelque part
son obstination voir son entêtement et
après cette crise certains observateurs
posent cette question comment faire
aujourd'hui pour avoir un vrai dialogue
démocratique avec Emmanuel Macron merci
Marion et je reprends ce que vous ce que
finalement la tout cela se lit Florent
Vaillot pour pour renouer le dialogue
avec les syndicats c'est ce que Emmanuel
Macron a tenté de faire aujourd'hui
c'est mal parti on va on va revoir je
pense qu'en régie vous allez pouvoir me
suivre vous aurez qu'on récupère le
tweet de Laurent Berger qu'on a qu'on a
vu sortir très très vite après
l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron ou le
leader le secrétaire général de la CFDT
parle de déni et de mensonges je vais le
citer denniez mensonge la CFDT à un
projet de réforme des retraites Macron
2019 l'avait compris il avait repris
notre ambition d'un système universel
Macron 2023 refait l'histoire et ment
sur la CFDT pour masquer son incapacité
à trouver une majorité pour communauté
sa réforme injuste pourquoi parce que
Emmanuel Macron disait grosso modo bah
nous on a on a une réforme et en face on
nous propose rien bon
le secrétaire
il s'en est pris donc on peut comprendre
la réaction de Laurent Berger c'est mal
parti c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
évidemment il y a une réforme il y a une
loi travail qui est qui va arriver je ne
sais pas dans combien de temps mais
Emmanuel Macron avait l'air de vouloir
que que le délai soit court avec qui
autour de la table c'est ça la question
du soir c'est mal parti mais pas
nécessairement sur la durée en réalité
d'abord parce qu'il y a des congrès
syndicaux qui vont trancher des lignes
assez stratégiques c'est le plus
important à mes yeux c'est celui de la
CGT et puis surtout Emmanuel Macron il
sait que si certains syndicats notamment
les syndicats réformistes sur d'autres
sujets que la réforme ne se viennent pas
à la table des négociations et bien ils
seront marginalisés et il y aura par
exemple pour la CFDT une tenaille dans
laquelle elle ne pourra pas être c'est à
dire que si Emmanuel Macron négocie avec
le Medef et les organisations patronales
que la CGT ne veut pas négocier par
exemple la CFDT perdra un tout petit peu
de son aura donc je pense que en réalité
il a eu tort et je vous rejoins de dire
que dans quelques semaines il allait
pouvoir reparler au syndicat mais en
dans la réalité il a raison parce que
dans quelques semaines il reparlera au
syndicat sur sa loi sur la pénibilité
sur les ruptures de carrière et là
évidemment que les syndicats réformistes
devront retourner à la discussion
peut-être en rappelant leur opposition
et qui rimente etc mais je pense que si
jouera un positionnement dans le paysage
syndical qui sera absolument déterminant
pour ne pas laisser à d'autres syndicats
le soin de monter alors il y a une autre
dimension que moi j'ai trouvé
passionnante dans le dans l'intervention
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est cette feuille de
route qu'il donne à Elisabeth borne
évidemment d'élargir sa majorité Mathieu
l'exécutif peut-il y arriver alors il y
en a pas le choix d'une certaine façon
si le gouvernement veut continuer à
gouverner le problème c'est que c'est
plus facile à dire qu'à faire dans son
interview d'aujourd'hui le président de
la République a donné un semblant de
mode d'emploi en invitant le
gouvernement à élagir la majorité avec
les hommes et les femmes de bonne
volonté
si tous les gars du monde décidaient des
copains ça c'est ce que dit la chanson
en politique c'est le problème c'est que
c'est toujours un petit peu plus
compliqué alors l'idée la plus simple ça
aurait été de négocier un accord de
gouvernement qui ben elle est parce que
c'est les seules susceptibles de le
signer mais malgré les appels du pied on
le sait de Nicolas Sarkozy de certains
ténors de la droite personne n'a voulu y
aller puis quand on voit le succès de
l'accord négocié par Isabelle borne avec
les chefs de fil des républicains sur le
dossier des retraites on se dit que
c'était peut-être pas une si bonne idée
ce matin Édouard Philippe a remet une
couche en appelant une coalition des LR
aux élus de gauche qui ne se retrouvent
pas dans la nupesse force est de
reconnaître que ça fait quand même pas
grand monde mais pour l'instant on n'est
pas là d'y arriver une majorité qui peut
aussi se bâtir texte par texte ça c'est
la seconde option c'est pas d'accord de
gouvernement mais c'était le pari
d'Elizabeth borne un coup à droite un
coup à gauche disons du camp de du temps
de Michel Rocard on parlait de majorité
stéréo il faut reconnaître que ça plutôt
fonctionné sur certains textes depuis le
début de la législature on l'a vu sur la
loi de programmation du ministère
intérieur on l'a vu sur les énergies
renouvelables on l'a vu encore très très
récemment puisque c'était sur le
ducléaire et le problème c'est que c'est
assez hypothétique parce que c'est et
puis surtout très chronophage ça prend
beaucoup de temps et puis ça dessine pas
forcément une ligne politique et puis ça
peut capoter je vais pas revenir sur
l'exemple des retraites alors il y a une
autre option le débauchage alors là
c'est des élus 1 à 1 alors là encore
plus compliqué par ailleurs l'exécutif
n'est pas en mesure de dicter sa loi ni
en état d'attirer grand nombre faut le
dire c'est pas l'Union qui fait la force
en politique c'est la force qui fait
l'union et quand le pouvoir est faible
mais il nagrège personne autour de lui
d'où une dernière option qui se dessine
et si on faisait moins de loi puisqu'on
a pas de majorité ça paraît bête quand
on y pense mais si on peut plus faire
adopter autant de plus en faire du tout
alors il y a des solutions il y a des
choses qui peuvent se régler par la
nation négociation entre partenaires
sociaux la valeur du contrat à
opposition à la loi ça peut se faire
comme ça d'autres qui peuvent se régler
par des craies mais surtout le président
de la République insisté par cette
petite phrase on en parlait tout à
l'heure tout ne passe pas par la loi et
puis la même promis d'être moins de
tests de loi puis les textes plus clair
plus courts est-ce qu'il faut comprendre
plus technique donc avec moins d'enjeux
ou de coûts politiques histoire de leur
donner plus de chances d'être adopté
faute de majorité on saucissonne tranche
après tranche dans une tactique du
salami revisitée et puis quand ça
fonctionnera plus bah il restera l'arme
de la dissolution et ça on le sait c'est
un fusil à un coup et on peut se tirer
une loi dans le pays alors évidemment il
y a plusieurs thèmes on va on va
reprendre certains et je commence Marcel
Foucault avec cette espèce de mission
impossible pour pour réaliser à bed
bornes élargir sa majorité ça n'a pas
été possible depuis le début de ce
second quinquennat pourquoi enfin ça
l'est encore moins maintenant c'est un
peu l'impression qu'on a oui puisque il
a répété qu'il faisait confiance à
Elisabeth borne pour continuer de mener
ce gouvernement alors je retiens quand
même cette option à laquelle je n'avais
jamais pensé moins légiférer
effectivement ça peut être une méthode
couée d'une certaine manière c'est la
phrase d'Emmanuel
ça peut être la suite logique de ce qui
vient de se produire c'est à dire
presque la mise au banc du Parlement ou
d'une culture démocratique parlementaire
qui a été profondément absente et je
pense qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a toujours
pas totalement
pris en compte ce qui s'est passé en
juin 2022 lors des élections
législatives je pense que on peut dire
il lui manque une une majorité de
coalition mais les colissions elles se
construisent en général avant une
élection on n'attend pas le résultat il
y a quand même des accords des
plateformes qui doivent présider à la
possibilité de gouverner sur une feuille
de route commune ça peut prendre
beaucoup de temps mais ça ça prend
beaucoup de temps et c'est extrêmement
l'autre l'autre élément qui me semble
important autour de est-ce qu'il est
possible d'élargir la majorité ça va
prendre des mois et des mois après ce
qui s'est produit à l'Assemblée
nationale donc donc ça peut être quoi du
débauchage de quelques personnalités
c'est je crois que c'est ça ne suffira
pas par ce que ce qui s'est produit
quand même au sein du groupe LR est
assez révélateur des prochains mois
c'est-à-dire on est sur une réforme
certes sociétales mais si Emmanuel
Macron continue à mettre à l'agenda
exécutif une réforme sur enfin une loi
immigration une loi travail je n'imagine
pas un instant que l'ensemble des
parlementaires LR vont se rallier
derrière leur chef de groupe et au fond
pour Emmanuel Macron et cette et ce
gouvernement et puis un dernier point
dans cette difficulté à élargir la
majorité moi je crois que la menace de
la dissolution elle est
elle ne restera qu'au stade de menaces
pour l'instant parce que
les membres potentiels d'une majorité
élargie ont tous à perdre à une
dissolution donc Emmanuel Macron il a
même si la répéter dans son intervention
je suis responsable parce que je n'ai
pas de vue électoralisme je ne peux pas
être élu ça veut pas dire pour autant
que c'est un président qui a envie de se
livrer pour la deuxième fois à une
dissolution ratée donc je crois que
cette arme-là elle est elle est arrangée
dans le placard des mauvaises idées
politiques à vous entendre les les
autres j'ai l'impression qu'on a
Emmanuel Macron finalement condamné à
l'immobilisme alors qu'il a passé son
ses 30 minutes à dire le contraire mais
c'est un peu la sensation que qu'on a ce
soir en tout cas c'est vrai qu'il a pas
beaucoup d'armes pour se retourner mais
moi j'ai l'impression de vous écouter
c'est vrai que finalement la formation
principale d'aujourd'hui c'était que il
change pas du tout de méthode et au
contraire on est dans dans une volonté
de toujours aller se passer du Parlement
se passer des syndicats enfin c'est
vraiment globalement il y a du mal à
gouverner autrement pendant son
précédent quinquennat c'était facile
parce que il y avait la majorité absolue
et donc ils alignaient les lois comme
ils le souhaitaient cette fois-ci il est
bien coincé depuis la législatives 2022
de travailler avec le Parlement quand
même contrat et forcé parce qu'il a pas
de majorité absolue mais bon donc il y a
eu quand même encore une fois contre un
effort et un changement de méthode oui
au coup par coup c'est à dire de
négocier au fur et à mesure mais moi à
mon avis là ça va être plus compliqué
parce que tant qu'on purge pas cet
épisode de la réforme des retraites on
va avoir des parlementaires en effet qui
vont voter un petit peu ceux qui
voudront individuellement ce qui s'est
passé avec les républicains ce qui va se
passer dans notre groupe la seule chose
qu'il a c'est qu'il y a pas
d'alternative et il en a pas trop abusé
d'ailleurs ce midi sur cette sur cette
ce paysage là il y a pas d'alternatives
politiques c'est vrai que la motion de
censure même si à la failli passer à 9
voix ça ne représente pas une formation
politique qui pourrait la contrer qui
pourrait contrer la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron en tout cas pour l'instant après
il faut voir comment ça monte en
puissance de ce côté là des soucis dans
cette réforme des retraites c'est qu'il
s'est mis à dos le petit groupe
charnière liotte liberté indépendant
outre 20 députés quand même parce que tu
es pas si mal et qui était plutôt du son
triste de droite et de gauche qui
pouvaient voter assez facilement et là
juste pour revenir parce que vous en
avez parlé de il a dit un des lois plus
courtes mais alors peut-être qu'il peut
aussi prévoir des lois plus mieux faites
peut-être que c'est un souhait qu'on
pourrait faire parce qu'après 5 ans un
premier quinquennat et là un début de
quinquennat avec des lois qui ont été
quand même assez mal fabriqués puisque
les lois retraite une des choses qui a
coincé aussi à mon avis ça a commencé à
exploser avec ça c'était les pensions
minimum avec cette espèce d'amateurisme
en disant ça va concerner près de 2
millions de personnes finalement on
arrive à 10000 pareil sur les carrières
longues sur les femmes aussi aux
carrières longues je pense que là il
faudrait en arrêter avec la maturie
peut-être que le fait de faire plus
court ça sera un peu plus je reste sur
le le chapitre capacité ou possibilité
de d'élargir la la majorité du du côté
des LR la ligne d'un accord de
gouvernement elle est évidemment
ultra minoritaire toutes les réactions
presque aujourd'hui sont hostiles au
président de la République on en a
choisi une seule de Pierre Henry Dumont
qui est député LR du Pas-de-Calais
écouté nous sommes des députés qui avons
été élus pour être dans l'opposition
nous serons donc dans l'opposition ça
vous empêchera pas de voter certains
textes quand ils vont dans le bon sens
je pense par exemple à Hyères un texte
d'accélération de l'installation du
nucléaire en France nous avons toujours
défendu le nucléaire Emmanuel Macron
lors du premier quinquennat avait fait
voter une loi pour détruire 14 réacteurs
nucléaires en France il est revenu sur
sa décision maintenant il est devenu
pro-nucléaire tant mieux et donc ce sur
quoi nous avons toujours tenu nos
engagements je pense ici au nucléaire
nous le voterons et puis quand il s'agit
d'un accord de gouvernement je dis
j'insiste sur le fait qu'il y a un grand
danger il y a un grand danger de signer
un accord de gouvernement avec Emmanuel
Macron c'est que si demain il n'existe
plus à l'Assemblée nationale dans le
pays une opposition non populiste à
Emmanuel Macron nous aurons en 2027 soit
Madame Le Pen Monsieur Mélenchon
l'Élysée alors Florian est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec la fin de l'analyse
de ce député c'est alors si s'il y a
plus d'opposition on va dire de
traditionnel ou gouvernement c'est c'est
la voie dégagée pour Marine Le Pen ou
Jean-Luc Mélenchon oui je pense qu'il a
raison mais je pense qu'Emmanuel Macron
s'en fiche puisque par définition en 207
il ne sera plus acteur politique et moi
ce que je vois depuis quand même au
moins dimanche c'est que Emmanuel Macron
certaines féministres font tout pour
faire imploser LR absolument tout Aurore
Berger a été plus qu'une pétroleuse
vis-à-vis des républicains pour créer
une scission extrêmement franche
notamment dans son discours juste avant
le vote de la motion déjà dans ces
interviews dominicales qu'elle a réitéré
dans son discours lundi à l'Assemblée
nationale donc à moins que Aurore berger
était en roue libre absolu ce que j'ai
du mal à croire pour le président du
groupe majoritaire c'était qu'il y avait
une stratégie par ailleurs Emmanuel
Macron a mis en scène dans son interview
le deal qu'il a passé Gérard Larcher sur
les lois immigration puisque ils ont
tous les deux convenus que les lois
l'être aussi sonnés qu'elles allaient
arriver sur tel et tel donc yes parce
que la majorité sénatoriale lui est plus
favorable ensuite dans son discours il
faut quand même rappeler que les deux
thèmes qui ont été mis très en avant par
Emmanuel Macron c'est d'abord le retour
au travail avec la figure du RSA et du
smicard je cite par Emmanuel Macron et
l'ordre républicain et donc les deux
premiers marqueurs dans l'ordre de
priorité c'est le travail
l'industrialisation l'ordre républicain
l'écologie en dernier après la santé et
l'école et enfin donc vous nous dites
sur des marqueurs de droite pour
commencer il a été un Nicolas Sarkozy
sans sens politique dans cette interview
et puis enfin je pense que il y a une
stratégie de maintien de l'ordre
également qui consiste à durcir le
maintien de l'ordre pour séparer les
éléments radicaux l'extrême gauche la
gauche des
centristes et hommes de droite homme et
femme de droite qui vont manifester
et elle fait quoi elle récupère derrière
alors aujourd'hui elle a donné une
conférence de presse assez importante
vraiment en alternative d'Emmanuel
Macron de la politique sociale elle
s'est positionnée sur le pouvoir d'achat
elle est complètement en phase avec ce
qui se passe dans la rue et en même
temps elle est pas dans la rue donc elle
est pas mêlée ni aux manifestations ni
au syndicaté aux violences mais à la
qu'à récupérer tout alors bon c'est voir
un peu loin parce que 2027 c'est encore
loin mais moi je crois qu'avec ou sans
les LR c'est pas le problème les
républicains je crois on leur donne
beaucoup d'importance pour un groupe qui
est pas tenu pas tenable regardez ce qui
s'est passé la motion de censure on
s'est absolument pas où ils vont tirer
où ils vont voter ce qu'ils vont faire
et encore plus parce que là il parle de
nucléaire mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
comme idée ils savent absolument pas
donner des idées différenciantes ni
vis-à-vis d'Emmanuel Macron ni vis-à-vis
du rassemblement national depuis des
années les républicains il y a pas de
figure porteuse qui peut être un Sarkozy
version 2027 et il y a pas de thématique
il y a rien il y a rien qui ressort donc
je trouve que c'est leur donner beaucoup
beaucoup de poids peut-être qu'ils en
ont envie ils avaient l'occasion c'est
sont les seules réserves de voix pour
on a vu que ça marchait pas aussi bien
on peut parler d'occasion banquier pour
LR moi
ne rejoint pas la majorité
ils ont même dans la majorité quelqu'un
qui a envie de voir Philippe qui prône
l'ordre dans la rue l'ordre dans les
comptes qui est vraiment leur mantra il
y a pas une feuille de papier cigarette
et c'est une majorité où il y a pas
beaucoup de ténors et où il y a beaucoup
de de de carrière à faire
il y a des figures de la droite juste
sociologiquement c'est quand même très
important la classe d'âge des députés LR
souvenons-nous à la précédente
législature du cas de Guillaume
l'arrivée qui était quand même la droite
d'Attila et qui fait un virage sur
l'aile qui devient macrocompatible quel
était son calcul c'est que s'il ne
devient pas ministre dans les cinq
années qui viennent il n'aura pas de
trajectoire politique par la suite et je
pense qu'une partie des LR seront aussi
sensibles à ce que leur trajectoire
politique puisse bénéficier de un accord
partiel ou total de leur groupe et donc
de cette scission annoncée à niveau
parce qu'on a abordé un petit peu et
vous avez dit qu'il avait eu un discours
de droite vraiment et sur la police et
sur et il a parlé du Capitole moi je ne
sais pas parce que je n'ai pas fait de
reportage dans la rue ou quoi mais on
voit ici où là quand même sur Twitter et
remonter des reportages qui mettent en
scène quand même des policiers dans des
situations un peu compliquées pour eux
c'est vrai et on entend parler Darmanin
de 400 blessés ou quelque chose comme ça
mais pour les manifestants aussi et je
trouve qu'il faut le dire c'est
difficile de se rendre compte de la
réalité des choses moi je suis allé un
petit peu dans d'autres manifestations
mais pas le soir mais ça donne une
impression quand même d'un maintien de
l'ordre qui était jusqu'à maintenant
peut-être avec l'aide des syndicats qui
encadrait mais bien les manifestations
mais là qui est probablement débordé par
ces rassemblements qui sont plus du tout
le la même tonalité de manifestation oui
mais c'est plus du tout non plus la même
tonalité d'encadrement et sans rien
faire non plus non mais est-ce qu'il
faut casser pour casser je sais pas
après je comprends bien la difficulté
des policiers mais on voit remonter des
choses qui peuvent un peu choquer juste
parce que ce qu'on entend aussi
quelque chose qui se passe
commercial Foucault sur cette ce climat
de violence effectivement on voit c'est
c'est des débats qu'on a eu au moment de
la crise des gilets jaunes sur le le la
stratégie policière la méthode
policières est-ce qu'on parle de
violence policière violence légitime
violence illégitime là il y a eu de la
part de policiers des retours à leur
ministre du tutaga maintenant en disant
que la situation était plus difficile
plus critique plus
tendue pour eux policiers aujourd'hui
par rapport à ce qui vivait au moment
des gilets jaunes oui je suis pas un
expert de séance de sécurité et de et de
technique de sur la réponse politique
finalement et sur le positionnement
Emmanuel je pense qu'il faut le regarder
aussi du côté du côté de la justice
parce que certes il y a des arrestations
nombreuses depuis quatre jours sur des
manifestations spontanées et on voit
bien que là les services de maintien de
l'ordre sont parfois un petit peu
dépassés et donc oui j'ai eu
connaissance comme tout le monde des
témoignages qui laissent entendre qu'il
y a eu il y a eu oui répression assez
forte mais aussi des policiers blessés
du côté de la justice je trouve que
c'est intéressant parce que
il faut savoir si effectivement est-ce
que la justice est à disposition de des
forces de l'ordre là véritablement on
sera si on a un renforcement d'un
maintien de l'ordre qui vise à dissuader
que les mobilisations se poursuivent
dans les dans les prochains jours mais
dans son intervention Emmanuel Macron
effectivement vous avez raison de dire
que il employait le terme d'ordre moi je
suis toujours comme surpris que les
événements
gilets jaunes 3 ans 4 ans non finalement
pas été prises en compte dans une
lecture politique de la situation et
donc il était attendu que Emmanuel
Macron donne des éléments d'apaisement
je crois qu'il n'a pas
ni les jeunes parce que depuis quatre
jours ce sont beaucoup de jeunes et plus
de jeunes ça c'est beaucoup plus de
jeunes d'ailleurs on n'a pas entendu
dans son discours des éléments de
réponse à une à une jeunesse dont on
sait qu'elle est quand même moi je
nationale universel qui est en
préparations
en tout cas des éléments de langage qui
ne vont pas véritablement rassurer ceux
qui se mobilisent chaque soir il nous
reste un peu moins de 5 minutes il y a
un dernier thème que je voudrais aborder
vous avez évoqué la conférence de presse
de Marine Le Pen à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est intéressant d'ailleurs de comparer
celle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et celle de
Marine Le Pen c'est le Marine Le Pen il
y avait le côté institutionnel de
l'Assemblée derrière évidemment et elle
s'est attaquée notamment à la première
ministre Elisabeth borne qu'elle dit
pulvérisée
le gouvernement a gagné pardon n'a pas
perdu de 9 voix
mais madame borne sort pulvérisé de
cette séquence
le vote de confiance ne peut
s'interpréter que comme une
manifestation de défiance bien sûr du
gouvernement mais disons le aussi du
président qui dans les coulisses
élyséennes tiraient les ficelles des
grosses ficelles de ce tour de magie
raté un président de la 5e et
normalement protégé par son premier
ministre mais quand le chef de l'État
cumule de manière évidente et a fortiori
revendiquer les fonctions
présidentielles et gouvernementales il
ne peut s'exonérer pulvérisé voulez-vous
entendre pour terminer sur ce sur ce
choix des mots de Marine Le Pen
Elizabeth borne était le pulvérisée
quelle capacité elle va avoir à
effectivement voilà tenir cette feuille
de route que je disais quasi impossible
donné par Emmanuel Macron c'est vrai que
ils avaient des bornes elle est mise en
grande difficulté il y avait l'indiscret
du Canard Enchaîné qui dit que l'Élysée
cherche à la prolonger à tout prix alors
qu'elle est qu'elle serait épuisée on
ressort les phrases où elle dirait que
son gouvernement est composé à moitié de
débile donc tout ça je cite
que les propos qui lui sont prêtés
par des confrères à vous et donc
effectivement là on sent qu'Elisabeth
borne elle est ciblée par toutes les
oppositions
souvenons-nous du discours de Mathilde
panneau vous céderez vous céderez vous
céderez à Elisabeth borne et à elle
seule elle ne parlait pas au
gouvernement elle parlait Elisabeth
borne je pense que les oppositions ont
besoin d'une victime expiatoire pour
remporter une victoire symbolique ou pas
mais montrer que la mobilisation n'a pas
servi à rien et que si la loi passe
c'est elle est validée par le Conseil
constitutionnel et que rien ne change
comment tenir un discours de
mobilisation dans les semaines à venir
pour comment dire aux gens de retourner
à la rue comment faire leur demander
leur faire confiance sinon rien obtenu
et donc dans un dispositif de grandes
fragilisations pour la première ministre
avec des ministres qui n'ont pas
forcément envie de lui prêter une grande
espérance de vie il faut à mon sens
avoir le trophée Elizabeth borne pour
permettre cela mais pas tout de suite
parce que Emmanuel Macron n'aime pas
céder à la pression oui mais très
longtemps
[Musique]
que quand on a un francriester donc qui
est ministre et qui dit lui-même que la
loi est mal faite notamment pour les
femmes il avait il avait il avait assumé
le fait que les femmes étaient
pénalisées mais simplement pour revenir
donc pas de remaniement parce que
problème de ressources humaines et puis
si c'est quelqu'un qui fait trop de
lumière qui prend trop la lumière comme
Édouard Philippe en un temps Emmanuel
Macron il n'aime pas trop ça mais moi
j'étais étonné qu'elle le s’en prennent
à Isabelle en plus on l'a entendu dire
qu'elle elle voudrait pas Matignon mais
peut-être parce qu'elle ne voulait pas
justement Marine Le Pen peut-être parce
qu'elle ne voulait justement pas
s'attaquer en direct à Emmanuel Macron
parce que on le sait très bien dans les
manifestations c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
est visé c'est vrai qu'elle peut être
mise en faiblesse pour sa technicité et
son manque de négociation de
concertation mais sinon la réforme des
retraites c'est pas Elisabeth borne
c'est Emmanuel Macron qui la porte et
c'est lui qui est critiqué au sein des
manifestations parce qu'on critique
globalement c'est un dernier mot
politique il faut aller vite martial
Foucault sur la probabilité la plus
forte c'est que Emmanuel Macron
pour la renommée et qu'elle crée un
nouveau gouvernement mais dans quoi dans
un mois dans
cristal mais non mais je crois que la
séquence où Elisabelle borne déposerait
sa démission et pour moi et passer
maintenant c'était la semaine passée
après le vote vendredi à l'Assemblée
nationale avec un remaniement mais je
crois que là on a pas besoin de
forcément d'une démission de la première
ministre il peut y avoir simplement des
changements de ministres non mais
rappelons aussi un point puisque il
reste peu de temps Emmanuel Macron et le
premier président qui a convaincu cette
première ministre d'avoir un ministre du
renouveau démocratique je pense que dans
ce qui vient de se passer au-delà des
retraites c'est la question de la
pratique démocratique pour ce
gouvernement qui est profondément remise
en cause merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat voilà c'est
la fin de ce numéro de sens public je
vous dis à demain et notez que on
reparlera DLR demain matin sur le
trentaine puisque Olivier Marleix
président du groupe ler à l'assemblée
sera l'invité Dorian Mancini dans la
matinale belle soirée